hello
and welcome to trigonometry i'm francis
foster i'm constantine kitchen and this
is a show for you
if you want honest conversations with
fascinating people
we are delighted to say that our
fantastic guest today
is a former chancellor of the exchequer
under the margaret thatcher government
lord nigel lawson welcome to
trigonometry
thank you it's a great pleasure to have
you on the show
uh as i mentioned you were responsible
for running this country's economy for
over six years i believe
uh in the 80s uh and
you're now well into your ninth decade
on this planet have you seen anything
like the sort of economic disaster that
this country is facing at the moment in
your time
no i haven't it is appalling
and i am
afraid that the way we're heading
into a disaster
and when when you when you talk about
the direction we're heading just for
ordinary people who watch the show who
may
not be economists or experts on this who
don't have your level of expertise can
you just elaborate on what you see
coming down the line
for this country well the
most serious thing i see coming down the
line
he's nothing to do with his academic
nothing to do with the coronavirus
i think that although this lockdown
has almost certainly done more harm than
good
uh there's clearly a very good
livelihood
there's at least one vaccines they come
up with
and i hope the others as well but at
least one of them
uh will work and we will escape
from this pandemic and its consequences
the problem is the completely gratuitous
disaster which i'm afraid to say
boris johnson who i like but if he
this has
set out the so-called green industrial
revolution
is 10.9 this is the
uh biggest and economic disaster
and the thing is and he seems determined
to do so
that has happened in my lifetime
which is quite a long lifetime as you
pointed out
i was trying to emphasize your level of
experience rather than to say anything
about how old you are that was
that was the goal but you mentioned this
green
strategy a lot of people will think that
you know the climate change is an issue
that we need to tackle
uh some people say this is an
opportunity to do that what is your
concern with that economic strategy
well the strategy incidentally
i think that climate change is not
a threat it's happening very gently
at a fraction of a degree
per decade which is something we can
perfectly well live with
but the the problem is that this the
circle strategy
with green industrial revolution is to
move away
from cheap uh
affordable and reliable energy
to extremely costly and unreliable
energy
and to do so at an inordinate cost
all the experts for example professor
michael
kelly and everybody else who knows about
this story
and i know a little bit about energy
because
before i became chancellor i was
secretary of state for energy
so it's not a new field
but the the cost
of moving from cheap and reliable energy
to very expensive and unreliable energy
is massive and it's crazy and i really
worry i've never
worried so much about the
future but of the british economy and
therefore
of this country uh more than i do now
nigel you saw lord lawson you you're
talking about this
energy specifically what do we mean
is it wind is it uh solar panels what
type of energy resources are we talking
about here
well the biggest thing that
uh johnson wants to move to
is wind which is hugely expensive
and very unreliable the wind people will
tell you that the costs
although that high now are coming down
that is
totally untrue they are if anything
going up
so it is sort of a burden
for the british people of their energy
costs the cost
for travel because they're heating their
home every other
cost involved in energy is going to
increase
really substantially hugely unless
the he has the sense
to to abandon this crazy plan
and lord lawson look again i'm an
absolute
layman i i don't know
and i don't know the first thing about
energy and all the rest of it but
my question is why at the time of a
global crisis
the pandemic when our economy looks ever
more unstable
are we embarking on renewable energies
that's a very good question a very good
question
i think that it's partly
um because this has become
this greenery has become something
of a new religion at a time when
christianity and other
religions are less and less
in people's minds and hearts and
thinking but also i think it is
a designed to
take our minds off the pandemic
but it's crazy lord lawson
you were chancellor the ex-check as i
mentioned if
a conservative prime minister i'm sure
the one you served under wouldn't have
done this but if a conservative prime
minister had walked into your office and
said
uh chancellor what we need to do at this
time when we're facing the worst
economic situation for 300 years is to
embark on this
what would your words have been to that
prime minister
i would be fabulously certainly margaret
thatcher
wouldn't have dreamt of anything so
stupid
and i'm afraid that
i would do my best
to dissuade the prime minister said that
and if not
i would leave the government
it's an interesting thing also that it's
a conservative government that's doing
this
i mean of all the different parties that
we have you would have thought
they might have been the least likely to
have done this would you not
i would have thought that it is crazy
i think you have to see it
to a certain extent in the psychology
of boris johnson who loves
big projects irrespective of the cost
and lord lawson we're i'm looking at
this conservative government
and this government to me doesn't seem
particularly conservative
and it doesn't seem very right of center
on economics
do you think this is a conservative
government
well it is a conservative government but
uh
one has to see things as they are
and assess this project the
green industrial revolution and it is
absolutely mad i mean i of course
ironically although it's mad the
neighbor opposition is supporting it as
you know
so because it seems to me that in this
country
we don't really have any credible
opposition if you look at for instance
the issue of lockdown
the govern the labor government wants us
locking down even harder even faster
all the rest of it now you're talking
about this green revolution which is
going to cost the taxpayer even more
which is going to make our energy source
more unstable again the labour
government are not putting any form of
uh opposition their way so quite frankly
does it
it does seem we're in a form of
political crisis now
well certainly you're right and that's
why i said a
few moments ago that i've never been
more depressed about the future for this
country
i mean i hope that uh
the government might come to its senses
and abandon this path but it is
absolutely a commitment
they've made so far but it's it's a
suicidal commitment
and setting that to one side loss and i
understand it's an important issue of
course it is
but if we just rise above it a little
bit and look at the bigger picture of
the economy
from your vantage point what do you see
more broadly in terms of the the cost of
the lockdown the cost of
of the pandemic which has been great as
well not only the response to but the
pandemic itself it's obviously taken
lives it's
it's forced us to reorganize the the
national health services forced us to
focus
uh resources in a different way and
what do you see for the country you know
setting the green agenda aside
well i'm sorry to be so gloomy
but he there are a number of things
about the economy
at this present time uh before the green
industrial
revolution uh has got going as you know
i hope he never will but the
boris johnson seemed determined to do it
but the the project at the moment
the situation at the moment with this
massive
deficit budget deficit with the
huge massive
debt uh burden
of the country uh that in itself
is quite alarming it's not necessary
to have a destiny i mean i
was able to bring the country
around turn the country around from a
deficit not as big as this one now but
pretty big
to a balanced sponsorship indeed
a very small surplus and it's perfectly
possible to do it
but at the moment everything's going in
the wrong direction
and how how would you do it now how
would you begin to tackle the deficit
and the massive mounting debt that we've
incurred
and let's be clear it's not just
something that's happened in the last
eight months we we've been building up
this
debt and expanding our deficit which
contributes to it
for for decades now well you have to do
it obviously on both sides of the
balance sheet
you have to cut back on
uh government spending uh which to a
certain extent
in his latest statement uh rishi soon
after president chancellor
has started to and you also
have to do a bit on however unpalatable
on the side of raising taxation and
how severe do you because we had
austerity we had austerity in 2008 and
it lasted
however long it was i think almost 10
years do you see us going into a second
austerity now
you might call it that um but yes
that's what needs to be done yeah and
but how severe do you think these
austerity measures are going to be are
they going to be
deeper and harder than they were in 2008
well they we said they should certainly
need to be
hazard uh even now because of the
consequences of the pandemic uh
they'll certainly have to be like that
and after we survived that
it wasn't a disaster we survived that
period of possibility
uh the world didn't come to an end
but i certainly a lot of people would
argue that
it was painful for many many people it
some people would say it led to a rise
in crime due to a reduction in the
number of police forces
we can go down the list you know
obviously all of that can be
can be debated um but i i don't know
that
uh and this is less of a question more
of a statement really i don't know that
many people
recognized at a time when follow was
introduced when
self-employment grants were introduced
when the lockdowns were introduced
the impact it would have on their lives
and i wonder frankly if that had been
explained to them
whether we'd seen the same level of
enthusiasm for the lockdowns that we've
had
well no the enthusiasm for the lockdown
i think is
is misguided i think the evans
is accumulating uh that
the harm done by the lockdown
is greater than any good uh you have to
make tough choices
and you never find in in government
that everything you do could be all good
and now harm is always a mixture
but you hope to what you do the good
outweighs the heart
i don't think they're locked up but this
is not
the main concern because i think it is
likely that uh once the vaccination
i hope it happens straight away at least
once the vaccination
is cleared as being safe and totally
effective
that the knockdown
will come to an end the
problem for the economy
doesn't go just like that
the body creates greatly diminishes
see one of the problems is that the
scientific advisors who
advise the government on the response to
the pandemic uh
have openly said that they don't take
the economic consequences
into account they say they set it to a
house of commons committee that's a
matter for the treasury
but uh
boris johnson has wanted to cover for
everything
so he thinks that if he can say well
this is what my scientific advisers
recommend then that gives him a
political cover
that he would like there are
extinguished ranches like
uh professor gupta
um oxford who has also said that she's a
scientist
a distinguished scientist who's a lot
done doing more hard than good
francis do you like exploring your
englishness every single friday night
night
really what do you do well you read a
book do you i do actually
it's called exploring englishness and
it's a book
written by a trigonometry fan called
vivian endicott
and you know it's good because this is
the first book i've ever seen i'm
reading
joking aside as you know i am now a
british citizen
but i'll still always think of myself as
russian for tax purposes
having said that if my children grow up
in this country having been born here
and think of themselves as still russian
i'd be disappointed i feel like it was a
failure on my part to educate them to be
part of this country
that is the wonderful thing about this
book is it allows you to explore
details of english culture to do
activities to go on
quests so the nerd and we really enjoyed
that the thing that i loved about
exploring englishness was a way that it
avoided
angry identity politics and instead
focused on what makes this country great
the beautiful landscapes the wonderful
art the exquisite cuisine
he means craigs exploring englishness
was a finalist at the dorchester
literary festival
this year and it makes for a great
christmas gift the book is 20 pound and
available directly from the publisher
ginger pop publishing go to www
dot ginger pop publishing dot co dot uk
and order your copy in time for
christmas just be aware
the only ship to uk addresses
well that's certainly the view that we
we've come up to on on this show
talking to different doctors and experts
in the field i
but from you know you mentioned
economics is it not the job of the
government to recognize that
an economic impact that leads to an
economic downturn that leads to people
being unemployed also has consequences
on people's well-being on the number of
people who die on the number of people
who sadly commit suicide all of those
things surely must be taken into account
when these political decisions are being
made
well they should be i mean you're quite
right that
the economic
cost of the policy which
is very considerable uh includes
obviously people losing their jobs
people losing their livelihoods and a
lot of
uh mental uh
harm so it's not you know it's not just
some
abstract or uh abstract thing
it is it has a mental uh health cost
uh as well as the economic costs they go
together
and lord lawson what do you think
it's absolutely fine lord lord what do
you think
is going to be the economic picture for
us when we finally emerge out of
lockdown
do you think it's going to be very
similar to a 1930 style scenario with a
great depression or dare i say could it
possibly be even worse
yeah i don't know whether it'll be
worse if we if the government
abandons this appalling
disastrous proposal for the green
industrial revolution
um then it might not be worse than the
30s
it'll be very bad but the 30s were very
bad too
it'll only be worse than the 30s if
he goes down this green industrial
revolution
route you mentioned
boris johnson and you said that you like
him as a person but you have concerns
about some of his policies
uh there was a broader question we
wanted to ask you because
uh the government you were part of with
margaret thatcher
at its helm uh is a government that will
be hated by many people who watch the
show
and it will be loved by many people who
watch the show
but neither the people who hated that
government nor the people who loved it
could possibly deny that it was a
government made up of the big beasts of
politics
margaret thatcher yourself and dozens of
others and
people frankly on opposite benches who
were equally significant political
figures
uh in this country at the time do you
feel that we have
the same caliber of politician as we did
in your time in government
well it's difficult for me to be
objective obviously
but i think it was a good uh era
for the quality of uh politicians
the good ministers and uh
but there you go i mean there's always
fractures doesn't it
it does but surely you look at the
caliber of politicians being produced by
both ends of the spectrum and they both
appear to be weak lacking in character
vigor etc etc do you not find
well you said that i wouldn't
argue with you but
the um the thing also is
that uh margaret thatcher
was a very fine
leader which helped a great deal
but not just that and
you were saying i think or maybe
constantine was
that people loved her but they also
hated her
clearly until right at the end anyway
um the majority of the people
supported her i mean she wouldn't have
won three general elections on the trot
if the people as a whole had not
approved of
her government
no of course my point was uh slightly
different
um what i was saying was even people who
hated her who i absolutely accept your
point were in the minority
none of them would have questioned the
caliber of politician that she was
whereas today i think there frankly
there are politicians who i like and
agree with
whose caliber leaves a lot to be desired
because they seem to be
the best of what's on offer
and that seems to to be a concern to
many people that
um we don't have the big beast of
politics anymore and the conviction
politicians are very few and far between
well that may be so but there are some
individuals who are
uh uh able uh
the president chancellor always very
young i think he's very able indeed
and what have you thought of boris
johnson's leadership i mean he
has come to power at a time of
national crisis the one of the biggest
challenges this country certainly has
faced certainly since the second world
war
how have you perceived his leadership to
be
he is very likable and
people like amazing people like him
and that's how he managed to win a large
majority
in the last election some people call it
charisma in fact that's a fancy name
for being likable and
but he also is a sucker
for big projects
you remember this ridiculous bridge over
the thames
he wanted to build when he was mayor of
london
and uh any big project
he is a sucker for and
the problem now is that he's
come up with the granddaddy of all
big projects and the fact that it is
totally
uneconomic and it's not economic not in
the sense that
the cost of the taxpayer be enormous but
the cost
to any everybody's electricity bills
even if it can be done absolutely which
is not clear because
everybody's earning wheels their heating
bills
their cars and so on uh
will be completely unaffordable and
that's why no other country in the world
is doing it
so so it does does beg the question then
why is he doing it
is it purely ego is it because he
he genuinely believes in this project
what why do you think the reasons are
well you have to ask him but why do i
think
i think he gets swept away
by the idea of this
as the french is called
and uh he doesn't bother about the cost
or the economics or anything like that
so it is very important that
his colleagues talk him out of this
before
he feels that he's gone in too deep
and can't uh extricate themselves
to take a small or smaller example of
this
is hs2 was not his
uh project but
it is a big project and it is
immensely costly not as big as this
green industrial revolution
and the costs get higher and higher
each time they're revised and there's no
economic case
for to at all but the
feeling is too often that
uh once you have already invested
a lot of money in the project you have
can't stop it otherwise the money is
wasted
that is foolish in the extreme
uh once you've taken the wrong decision
then you need to stop it you don't go on
just because
you took the wrong decision in the past
which you passed
and they've spent a lot of money on it
you stopped digging and you you've
talked
uh just changing tax slightly you've
talked about
boris johnson's pongxion for grand
projects
there was one you might call grand
project
which was the centerpiece of his
election in
2019 which was of course of course
getting brexit done
uh what is your view of where we are now
with brexit because frankly
uh francis insisted that we talk about
it with you whereas i am sort of i think
more where most of the public are at the
moment where it's been it's become a
third-rate issue in many people's minds
although of course it is very important
um where are we with brexit and what do
you see happening with that are we
heading towards no deal
i've always thought that
no deal would be the outcome there is no
way
that
the european union
want to see us have anything that is
remotely like
a good deal and that's not because
they're anti-british
it's because there is a lot of lifting
the european union for nearly 20 years
and it is not
uh because they want to uh
do down britain as such it is the
there is a lot of disaffection with the
european
union in many parts of the european
union
and they feel that if we
uh get out and thrive
that will be a an example
to other countries who might do the same
thing might collapse so
they want to make sure that there's no
way
we can come out of it in a way that
we certainly i would find exceptional
uh and there's nothing wrong
with no deal uh no deal means that we
trade
on world trade organization wto terms
uh which is perfectly acceptable and
that is how
we do most of our trade trade outside
the
european union and uh we have no trade
agreement
for example in the united states and we
trade on a very large scale
with the united states we trade we will
continue to
trade on the wto terms and that
and that's how most of the world's trade
is conducted
but but surely lord lawson this is going
to have a hugely detrimental impact on
our economy
uh it's going to cause widespread
disruption
we've had matthew paris on the show who
said that no deal was going to be
is going to be disastrous but you you
disagree with this
yes completely i don't think matthew
paris will be
the most entertaining journalist is
has any great knowledge in economics the
uh if we have no deal
how we do economically is going to be
dependent
on how well we conduct our economic
policy
which is a matter for us outside the
european union i mean self-government
is not a terrible thing you know
we gave self-government
to huge numbers of
uh countries within the british empire
come on commonwealth if you like and uh
it is astonishing and this was commended
that we
gave them self-government it's very odd
that people don't think we're capable of
governing ourselves
are you tired of using bulky old wallets
that give you a bulge where you don't
want it to be
if you are ridge wallets are an
incredible solution this is mine
sleek look at the industrial look as
well it's great you can have 12 cards in
it and cash on the back with a clip or
strap
they're incredible we've got one for the
whole team francis has one i have one we
even got anton one banson's from
liverpool he flogged on the black market
absolutely he did and it also gives you
a
lifetime guarantee which means that you
will probably if you won't only have one
wallet
for the rest of your life the amazing
thing about ridge wallets they are so
confident in their product and rightly
so
that they will give you 45 days to test
drive
their product that means you get the
wallet you use it and if you don't like
it you can return it within 45 days
and because ridge are such great guys
they're going to give you 10
off and free worldwide shipping and
returns
to take advantage of this fantastic
offer go to ridge.com
forward slash trigger that's ridge.com
forward slash trigger and use our code
which
will not surprise you is also trigger
would you would you deny that there
would be a lot of disruption though i
mean short-term disruption can be
a reasonable price to pay for for
long-term outcomes that you want
would you accept that and no deal would
be bad in that sense at least in the
short term
well there'll be some disruption
certainly but that's
not serious and of course don't forget
that we
would no longer have to pay the massive
annual
subscription we have to pay to be
members of the european union
that seems to have become forgotten but
it is very substantial you remember
at the beginning of the future
government there was a great
uh negotiation in fact it started under
labor
it was jim callahan who to begin with
we are paying a quite excessive
subscription
to the european union
and uh he didn't get anywhere
margaret thatcher took up the baton and
she did get
a rebate uh agreed
but it's only a partial debate
we're still net contributors
to the rest of the european union on a
large scale
so that has to be offset not having to
continue that
needs to be offset against the
short-term disruption
and the eu project many people have said
it's fundamentally doomed because of the
inequality between north and south
and particularly the euro what is your
opinion on that
yeah well that's that is that is
actually a fundamental
uh point the european union is actually
a political project
uh almost entirely a political project
and it began the idea began a long time
ago
uh with jean renee then
the idea is an economic means
to secure a political union
now that's fair enough if you want to be
part of a political union
but we entered it uh the time under the
misunderstanding
that it was just an economic project
in fact it was called in those days the
common market
and it's in progressively the
european the political nature
of the european union
which is not disreputable but i just
don't share it
and the british have never shared it uh
makes it wrong for this country
and unacceptable this country which the
people of this country
decided in the referendum i remember a
long time ago i knew
uh a leader of the real party who died
before he could become
prime minister hugh gatesville and he
was
passionately to
british membership of the european
communities i think it was called
in those days on precisely the scrum
because it was a political project
not an economic project at all and legal
project which
is not what
we in this country want to be part of
so as far as you're concerned we're
heading towards no deal
and that's fine and that's where we were
gonna get to anyway
well i i think that we could
uh sign a deal but it would be a very
bad deal
that's the only one that uh uh
negotiations
the other side of the table uh
will offer us and so i
uh think that we will most likely
end with no deal which is better than a
bad deal
and it's indeed it's the only way that
we can secure our freedom and
independence and have a warm and close
relationship with them i have no
possibility
and we have a warm and close
relationship with the united states but
that
doesn't mean we want to be part of the
united states
and what would you see uh lord lawson as
a future of the euro do you think it's
ultimately a currency that can survive
and thrive
or do you think that it's in its death
now
well it's certainly not thriving but at
the moment of course all
attention is focused on the pandemic
but the euro is certainly not
a thriving currency at all
but i think that it
creates problems for
a number of countries uh italy in
particular
in the european union and
we decided not to join the euro
which was absolutely right but of course
it means we're
having even less influence
uh on any european
union decisions than other countries
because what happens in the european
union the way decisions are taken
is that they have a meeting first
of the euro group the group of
countries in the european union who have
adopted
the euro as their currency and they
reach a conclusion
and once that conclusion is reached that
is a majority
in the european council and so we have
no influence whatsoever we've
never had a great deal of influence
within the
european council but it has
greatly diminished almost to zero uh
following the uh
coming of the euro and the euro group
which is an inbuilt
majority and doesn't need to concern
itself with countries
due to that but not adopting uh the
europe
including the united kingdom and lord
lawson
we we are obviously leaving and i mean
that has
it's been a palava but we're finally
leaving the european union next year
do you think that's going to be the
start of a domino effect with more and
more countries leaving the eu
it depends how we conduct ourselves
how um the
greater the success of the united
kingdom
outside the european union um
the more tempting it will be for
the people of other countries to say
well we might do that
and if we make a mess of things of
course
uh then it will be
less likely that other countries will
wish to follow our example
but i very much hope that we won't make
a mistake there's no reason why we
should
and as i said we will
be free from having a matrix massive
annual uh contributions or annual
subscription
to the european union coffers and
lawson if you look back to that election
or the referendum i should say in 2016.
and you see all the turmoil that has
happened in this country
the arguments the fact that it's a
highly divisive issue
do you still think that having that
referendum
was the right thing to do for the uk
absolutely there's no way we could
uh extract ourselves from the european
union
without having a referendum for british
people
uh such a big constitutional matter
uh that is needed referring i'm not
um in favor of frequent referendums
uh but on this issue that was the only
way we could
get out it was
ironic that of course
we would never
had the referendum uh david cameron
would not have
uh held a referendum if he hadn't been
convinced that the inns
would win uh but that was not the case
fortunately let me ask you a theoretical
question
if i may taking all of these issues
together the pandemic at the moment the
seeing brexit through the economic
challenges to do with lockdowns
uh and and with the pandemic as well uh
how do you think
the government that you were part of uh
as i said uh spearheaded by margaret
thatcher with you
as chancellor and others how would you
have dealt with with
the current situation that we find
ourselves in as a country
well if you uh mean
fossil dealing with a pandemic i think
that it
mythically very is but i think that we
have to
uh get the financial situation
uh the deficit and
the debt too but mainly the deficit
because if you can gradually eliminate
the deficit
then the debt burden stops increasing
it's still there
but stops increasing and that's crucial
i think we have to do that
and i think we'd have to do it by
a form of
rigor or austerity
which is in the short term
uncomfortable but
it is sometimes necessary i don't think
that uh just printing more and more
money
is a solution it doesn't is building up
more problems and of course you abandon
crazy projects uh in particular of which
the
uh green industrial revolution record
is the craziest and if we ever do embark
on it
which the government seems determined to
do or at least the prime minister seems
to turn into uh that
is uh will be the biggest
disaster and well attending tears but as
i say
i hate to do so i've always been
awesome uh lord lawson before we do our
last question there was something that i
wanted to ask you so i grew up in the
uh i in the 80s and and the 90s
if you look back at your government what
are the things that you are most proud
of
when you look back at the thatcher
government of the changes that you
implemented
things that you did ways that you moved
this country forward
well i think the most important thing
was turning the
economy around britain when we came into
office was a basket case and that's
probably
why we won the 1979 election
it wasn't because anybody was
i think swayed by
what we were saying it was just because
the economy was in such a mix
with strikes all the time uh
huge industrial unrest and
an economy which is regarded with pity
by countries around the world and we
turned it completely round
and at the end we were regarded as an
example
of how to conduct
economic policy successfully
and that increased our influence
considerably
and the there were a whole lot of things
which were
classical uh economic policy may be
but there are also other things which we
were complete innovators
and subsequently other countries have
copied us for example
privatization nobody had ever heard of
privatization
in fact there wasn't a word for it when
we entered office
we embarked on a massive privatization
campaign
which improved the working of the
economy considerably
and led to other countries uh around the
world
uh copying us following us and there
were
privatization policies in
became enforced in most countries of the
western world
and uh the main thing was
the successful conduct of
economic policy of the economy and
the wisest and trade union reform
incidentally
was part of that necessary process
and as you say we became an example to
the rest of the world
and lord lawson on the flip side as well
what were the mistakes that you thought
you made
in government because every government
makes mistakes and
yours was no different what were the
things looking back that you now go
we got that wrong or we handled that
badly before lord lawson answers can i
just say vladimir putin's government has
never made any mistakes
but i can't tell you this after these
laps of time
which uh what the mistakes were
everything
every government uh makes mistakes and
kept of course institutions
uh and if you
bother to read my memoirs i
um you will find i acknowledge
mistakes there in the memoirs and i
genuinely can't
remember what they were now
how very convenient
that is the best get out of jail free
card i've ever heard in my life lord
lord
it's been an absolute pleasure to have
you on the show we know you watch the
program from time to time and that that
is a big honor for us
to have you as a guest here before we
let you go
uh we should of course say everyone
should read your memoirs
but uh tell us what is in your opinion
other than the green industrial
revolution because i feel like you've
stuck the button on that one pretty hard
today
other than that one issue what is the
one thing that no one
is talking about that we really should
be
well i decided to be a ball but i think
that
close that eclipse is
everything else at the present time
and i am as i say i am very concerned
uh very concerned uh well i haven't got
much longer to
leave uh i'm concerned about this
country and of course
i have children and grandchildren so i
do care about the future
but uh i'm sure that
if there were anything else you would
have raised it
your confidence is extremely misplaced
lord lawson but we thank you
for it nonetheless uh it's been an
absolute pleasure speaking with you
we hope you at home have enjoyed it as
well and we will see you very soon
with another brilliant episode take care
see you soon guys thank you and bye bye
thanks for watching guys as always
subscribe to the youtube channel
click the bell button next to subscribe
button so you get notified when a video
comes out
and follow us on all the social media at
trigger pod
and also leave us a nice review on
itunes and spread the word